JOHN RYAN: So I actually
really am excited to be here.
I'm here because
last year, our team
ported our entire code
base on a new app to Dart.
And I'll be talking a
little bit about that.
And it's been a really
positive experience.
And reflecting back
on that experience,
and looking back
over the last year,
we're very convinced that
Dart's a great choice
for teams, and for
groups of teams,
building complicated web apps.
And we also believe
in Dart's mission
to make the web an even better
place to build those web apps.
So the title of this talk
is Switching to Dart.
I'm John.
I like to climb rocks when
I'm not writing software.
This is in Snow
Canyon, Saint George.
So this is a timeline
of our project.
We started prototyping
things a year ago.
We formed a product team in May.
We switched to
Dart last October,
after using a bunch of
tools in JavaScript.
And we shipped early this year.
We're very happy about that.
We're getting a lot
of good feedback
from internal and external
customers already.
And immediately after switching,
we have a lot of advantages.
We were just getting a lot
of development advantages.
So getting new engineers
on the team really sped up.
It only took about one or two
days for the three engineers
we had to start shipping
code for our app.
And that was really great.
We think the developer
experience is much, much better
than what we were doing before.
We focus a lot
less on our tools.
A lot less.
And we find code a lot
easier to share among teams,
using Pub and all the features
that are available there.
Does anybody know what this
chart is, by any chance?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN RYAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
It's for climbing.
So it's the Yosemite
decimal system.
And all these climbs are
graded on their hardest move.
And some of these
climbs are multi-pitch.
So you might have one
section that's considered
5.9 and one that's 5.11.
And this is just North America.
So if you're from Aarhus,
it would be different.
But the reason I'm showing
you this is, I think,
software and climbing
have a lot in common.
I think they're fundamentally
about problem-solving.
In fact, certain climbs
are called problems.
They're called molding problems.
And when you're
solving problems,
and you're seeing some
improvement in what you're
working on, or in what
your team is working on,
it's going to be a lot more fun.
And we think that
this starts a cycle.
And the more fun you
have, the more you
want to solve more problems.
And if you expand
this to the team,
I think it makes for a
good work environment.
And I think using good tools
is like using good climbing
technique.
And that's what we
want for our engineers.
So I'll talk about who we are.
I'll talk briefly about why
we evaluated Dart and switched
to Dart.
Very briefly, I'll
talk about how
we did it, and some
of the tools that
are available to make
that process easier,
and a little bit about
what we are doing today,
and how we're using
the tools today.
We make Wdesk.
And Wdesk is a complex
business reporting application.
And what that means
is a lot of companies
use our application for
documents, presentations,
charts, mobile apps.
And they use our full suite
of apps for this specific use
case.
And we're able to customize our
software for them, because we
deploy to the web, and
we get a lot of feedback
from them really quickly.
We can deliver features
multiple times a day,
and fix bugs, and get
feedback really quickly.
And we have over 65% of the
Fortune 500 using our product.
And that's really exciting.
And this is what
we attribute it to.
I think it's this
build-measure-learn loop.
It's our way of getting
feedback from customers.
And I think the Dart project
also wants this, too.
And so if we can give a lot of
feedback to the Dart project
while we're here,
I think they'll
be able to take that back and
build better stuff for us.
And that's what we do.
And that's what we're about.
So why did we switch to Dart?
Well, we primarily
build large-scale apps.
We were using JavaScript tools.
And we found them very difficult
to compose together, and get
working together
in a nice package.
And when we evaluated Dart, it
was a complete solution for us.
So I mentioned we build
large-scale applications.
We build Wdesk in ActionScript,
starting five years ago.
And it gave us a
lot of benefits,
and a really scalable language.
It has type information.
It's got build tools
in place for you.
When you're navigating code,
that works really well.
And Jetbrains has done a great
job over the last five years
working on ActionScript, and
getting that support in place.
And the libraries and
frameworks are there, too.
And so this is probably
sounding familiar to you.
Language tools and libraries.
And it just allowed
us to build Wdesk.
And I don't think we would have
built the same product had we
immediately gone to HTML5.
But there's some problems
with our current application.
It's over 1 million
lines of code.
And it takes two to eight
minutes to compile it.
And that's not a great
developer experience.
So for our new products,
starting last year,
and before that, we
were targeting the web,
and trying it make new apps
that solved this problem.
But the problem with
JavaScript is decision-making.
We had to decide
whether we were using
internal external modules,
AD, or common JS, what kind
of package manager
we were going to use.
Each of these arrows is
where we changed our mind.
Bundler, you have to have
Bundler to produce a compiled
JavaScript output.
And you have to have a
build and test framework.
And you have to glue all
these pieces together and hope
that something good comes out.
But after all that
work, we evaluated Dart
and found it to be
a complete solution.
So you have the great
developer experience.
And when we were
evaluating, we knew
we could work with existing
JavaScript libraries.
And I'll talk a little
bit more about that.
And there's a good
testing story around Dart.
And it's getting even better
with the new test package.
So we're really
excited about this.
And when we evaluated this,
this was really compelling.
So how did we switch?
Well, that's why we switched.
But how did we switch?
So I'll talk quickly about
our strategy for switching.
I'll talk about
React components.
There's been a lot
of interest in React
and why that helped us switch,
and we switched our unit test
over.
So our strategy was we had
four developers at the time.
We had a medium-sized code
base, maybe a small code
base, 13,000 lines of code.
It's not a small amount of code.
153 files.
And it only took
us about a week.
So there's a lot of
reasons for this.
And I'll get into that.
But I think it's
really cool that you
can take an app you've been
working on for five months,
and just switch it to Dart.
And we actually
shaved a lot of lines
off our code because of Dart's
package system, and how clean
that is, versus
JavaScript's module system.
So our strategy
looked like this.
We didn't really focus
on writing idiomatic Dart
code at first.
We just wanted to get it
working and switch it over.
And then, maybe, in the weeks
after we got our working app,
we could make the
code more idiomatic.
So for example, we weren't using
RXJS for these tooling reasons
I was mentioning.
But we did want a
stream-based model.
So we wanted to be able to
subscribe to some events,
and maybe receive
errors, and then--
so here, I'm calling Subscribe
to Model at the bottom.
And when we reported
this to Dart,
we really didn't focus
on changing this.
We just got the code
running the same way
it was running in JavaScript.
And we were done.
And then later, it's
really exciting.
And it's actually a lot of
fun to refactor the code,
and make it more idiomatic.
So you can see we're just
using a stream, here.
And we keep a stream controller
on our class called Thing.
And it's a lot cleaner.
And plus, you get all the
advantages of the stream class.
React components
were another thing
that was a challenge for us.
And we weren't sure how
this was going to work.
So for those who
aren't familiar,
this is a React component.
It's really simple.
It's written in JSX, which
is a little controversial,
because you're inlining
XML into JavaScript,
and then compiling
that, the JavaScript.
But it's actually
pretty simple to use.
And we like it.
So we had a lot of
components written in React.
And when this compiles,
it looks something
like this, where the div
element has no properties.
So we give it null.
And then we say, hello, name.
So when we ported this, there's
this library called React Dart.
And it allows you to
write normal Dart classes
and use the inheritance
model extend component.
And here, we're using
some string interpolation.
And yeah, it worked really well.
We have an engineer
here, Trent, who's
going to be giving a lightning
talk about React, if you're
interested in this binding.
And if you're interested in how
this works, you can check here.
So that was the
React components.
And we got those ported
over using that strategy.
The final thing we did
was port our tests.
And the Angular team has written
this library called Guinness.
So I'm going to go
back and forth here
between Jasmine and Guinness.
Boom.
So that's how we switched.
We took a strategy of just
moving the code over, and then
improving it after.
Move and improve.
Trademark.
React components were able to
be switched using React.Dart.
And then, using the Guinness
package, we switched our apps.
And now, we're
using a unit test.
But having that initial port go
smoothly was important to us.
So I'm going to
talk a little bit,
spend the rest time talking,
about what we do now
and how we're using
the tools today.
And we're seeing a lot of
awesome stuff happening
in a lot of these,
especially testing.
So this is really
exciting to talk about.
But the Dart VM just immediately
give us a great development
experience.
I don't think I'll get any
controversy saying this here.
Debugging is just really
fast and predictable for us.
We used the IDE Webstorm.
And we're able to
debug remote apps
and debug apps locally just
right in the source code.
That's really great.
I'll talk a little bit about
this on the next slide,
but switching branches is
really important to us,
because we review code.
And keeping a Pub server
running and switching branches
is a great developer experience.
Checked mode is also
really nice for us.
Being able to put certs in our
code and have those type checks
makes you understand the
bugs that much quicker.
And I have a quick example here
of something I think it's cool.
So I know there's a question
about using a REPL in Dart.
So this is something that you
can do if you set a breakpoint.
You can just start,
open up the console,
and just play with
different frames.
Here, I selected the package
I wanted to play with.
And I'm typing in a string.
And it's going to
parse it for me.
I'm a really fast
typer, as you can see.
So there we go.
It's going to parse that for us.
Cool.
So switching branches
is much cheaper.
And this is
important, because we
like to test each other's code.
And we like to
really quickly get
feedback on each other's code.
So we pushed to GitHub.
We set up a pull request.
And this was the
old workflow, where
we had to commit
our working changes,
compile and serve the
application, and that took,
in JavaScript, that
took 10 to 12 seconds.
We had a medium-size app.
And then, we review and
test the code like normal.
And then, when
we're done, we have
to go back to our old
branch we were working on
and check our working changes,
and then compile and serve
to get back running again.
So there's a mental block here.
It's not fun to, eh, maybe
I'll pull down this code,
but maybe I'll just keep
working on what I'm working on.
But with Dart, you just
keep the Pub server running.
And you can eliminate
those compile steps.
I know for me, it's a lot
less of a mental block
to just play with
each other's code.
I think Pub is awesome.
And we have found that it's
allowed us to share code
a lot more easily.
So we have this
notion of writing code
as classes and
functions, and not
really knowing what the
future of those will be.
And over time, we say,
well, we can abstract this
into a library and declare what
other libraries it imports.
And then in the same
repo, because Pub
has package dependency, or
path dependency, support,
we can put that into a package
in our same repository.
Keep the code reviews
in the same place.
And then, eventually
separate it into a repo.
And then, we open-sourced our
first Dart repo the other day.
So just really good story around
how flexible Pub makes writing
packages.
So there's a really clear
structure for Pub packages.
So actually analyzable.
So I'm not saying this
is clear structure.
But this is our dependency
for a package right now.
And Kevin made this.
It's really awesome.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN RYAN: The tool, yeah.
Yeah.
That's our code.
That's the mess.
So the Git versus
private Pub server
is one issue where I think
it would be cool to improve.
So there is a
private Pub server.
If you're a company
or you're a team,
you can host this on App
Engine, and, eventually,
just on your own server, and
share your code that way.
And what that gives you is
path constraint-solving,
or constraint-solving
for your package.
One other cool thing
that might work
would be to use get tags for
path or constraint-solving.
So if everyone wants
to get out their laptop
and vote for Issue
22481, I will stand here.
I'll wait.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN RYAN: But
seriously, though, I
think having a team dedicated
and responding to issues
quickly is really cool.
And we get that for
free from you guys.
Thanks.
So we bind to JavaScript.
We do this do through the
React binding that we use.
And we just do it for existing
libraries that we have,
and we haven't ported yet.
The first choice should
be to port to Dart,
but if you can't,
you can use this.
So here, I have a class.
I'm using this Promise object.
So I'm getting the
Quokka Promise object
from our JavaScript context.
And what that looks like
is something like this.
So we can actually wrap.
We're wrapping
promises and stuff
for simple libraries like that.
And we're just using
Dart JS right now.
There's a problem that
we have been seeing
with binding to JavaScript.
So here, if you pass a
function over to JavaScript,
they're not equal.
And I think this
is a huge problem,
because you can do something
like set timeout does, which is
return an ID for that listener.
And then, you can clean
those listeners up yourself.
But I think with the
stuff that's coming out,
I think this will improve.
So that's how we bind to JS.
It's worked really well for us
for the libraries that we have.
And it's only going
to get better.
We have a story around
CI that looks like this.
We push to GitHub,
our CI server.
It's an internal CI
tool that we have.
Pulls down our code.
And then it grabs the
Dart Docker container
from our Docker registry,
and then runs our test
using that Docker container.
Travis CI.
There's support for Travis CI
on their site for Dart, now.
But if you want to do this
and get a green check mark,
there's lots of Docker
files available.
So if you have some
base Docker image,
and you want to get your
tests and stuff running
on that Docker image, you
can download the base Docker
image that is shipped by the
Dart team and then use that.
Or, you can look at one
of these Docker files,
if you're interested
in how that works.
That works pretty nicely for us.
One of the final things
I'm going to talk about
is our testing story, and
something we think is cool.
We think WebDriver is really a
nice tool for running automated
browser tests.
So what WebDriver
allows you to do
is actually automate
real browser interactions
that user might
do-- click buttons,
and do all that sort of thing.
So it's a project
by the Selenium,
it's part of the
Selenium project.
And there's multiple languages
supported, and one of them
is Dart.
So I'll show you an example
of a Python test, here.
This is a synchronous test,
so each line actually blocks.
So there's a few advantages
to writing these in Python,
because you have some
interactivity with clicking
through the browser
and using the API.
But when we switched to
JavaScript a year ago
for our project, we
wanted to write our tests
in the same language.
And this was actually
harder to debug.
And we had some problems just
getting our WebDriver client
to be readable and
understandable.
So when we switched to Dart,
we used, at the time, the Dart
Async package.
We used Features.
And you can write
something like this,
where you're getting the URL,
you're finding the element
that you want to click on.
Then, you click on
it, set the text,
and check the text that
is what you expect.
But I remember the
first time I saw you
Async await was with our test,
because it was a preview.
And we could run our tests
using whatever we wanted.
And yeah, I knew it was a
feature that we were going
to really love and start using.
So that's WebDriver.
And the advantage to
running WebDriver tests
in the same language is that you
get the full power of the Dart
language.
You get anything
you would normally
use when you're writing code.
And we found that our
quality assurance engineers
and our developers can
collaborate and review
each other's code.
And that's been really
positive for us.
So that's what we do now.
We use the Dart VM.
And all the developer tools
give us a great developer
experience.
Pub allows us to share
code really easily.
Were still able to use
JavaScript in a way that's
sane and makes sense to us.
And we have a great
testing story.
And the testing story's
only getting better.
So we're really
excited for 2015.
So switching to Dart
has allowed us, I think,
to build, measure, and learn
more quickly, get features
out quicker, and get feedback.
It's a better
developer experience.
And having more fun
as a developer means
you're working hard,
getting better,
and that's what you want.
Just like climbing.
We focus a lot less
on tools, so it's
like climbing more efficiently,
when you're not messing around
with your harness, for example.
And code is much easier
to share between teams.
And overall, I just I think
it's the number one thing
we've done to be
more productive.
So looking forward, I think
there's some cool things
that we're excited about.
This notion of libraries that
are platform-independent,
like the HTTP package.
Really exciting
stuff, because you
can write a library
like a GitHub API,
run it on the server
or the client.
And you can also--
Dan Schultz has
an example of rendering React
components on the client
or the server, as well.
So that's something we're
looking into and getting
really excited about.
So we're here.
We've completed our first pitch.
We've been working for a year.
And we have shipped
our products.
And we feel like we've climbed
this last section much more
efficiently.
And when you climb
more efficiently,
you usually have the stamina
to look up and keep going.
So that's my talk.
If anybody has any
questions, I'll be here.
We have a lot of
Workiva engineers here.
And we're just really
glad to be here.
It's great to see all you guys.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Bob, I
don't know about you,
but I want to have
the Workiva guys just
always give our pitch.
BOB: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Why are we here?
Geez.
Actually, no, stick
around, though,
because we have
time for questions.
JOHN RYAN: Oh, OK.
Yeah, sure.
BOB: Guess what?
Any questions for John?
Back here?
I'll run.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So is Wdesk hosted?
Do you do any actual content
hosting on your site?
Or do they run it inter-office?
JOHN RYAN: Yeah.
So that's a great question.
Actually, we've been using
App Engine for a long time
to host our product.
And App Engine's a great tool.
We are still using
it today a lot.
So I think we're a really
large App Engine customer.
And now we can run
Dart on App Engine.
We're looking into that.
And that's exciting, as well.
BOB: Anyone else?
Ivan.
Oh, no.
IVAN: So I had a question
about the million
lines of ActionScript code.
When are you switching those?
And how would you go about that?
JOHN RYAN: Million lines
of ActionScript code.
I think our strategy
going forward
is we're building
new products in Dart.
And I don't see our
current ActionScript code
base moving very quickly.
But it's actually a great
reference for any new features
we're implementing,
because we can go back.
I think ActionScript
translates to Dart pretty well
in terms of how the
languages are structured.
And Dart is just a
very-- it's a language
that a lot of
languages are like.
It's a C family language.
And so it's not like we're
translating a whole bunch
of different concepts.
AUDIENCE: How many
lines of Haskell
do you have to translate?
JOHN RYAN: Zero.
BOB: Anyone else?
We have a live,
large-scale Dart user here.
Pick their brain.
AUDIENCE: What did you
use for the UI framework?
Did you pick anything
liked Dart or Polymer
or anything for the UI, or
just straight Dart HTML?
JOHN RYAN: Yeah.
Trent's going to be giving a
lightning talk a little bit
more about that.
We're using React for
most of our components.
And in some places, we just
use Dart HTML directly.
BOB: Got time for one
more, maybe one more.
Going.
Going once.
Going twice.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN RYAN: We are
using App Engine.
Yeah.
We've been using
it for a long time.
BOB: The question was,
are you using App Engine?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
JOHN RYAN: Thanks for
the clarification.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
JOHN RYAN: Thanks.